oh my God oh my God feral spit spit in
my mouth but what kind of bat like a
baseball bat someone's Sun sent this
Drew Starkey and Jonathan Davis sexy
asses back on my screen in 2023. tight
oh no it won't be
somebody
hi I'm Madison Bailey I'm Drew Starkey
I'm Jonathan Davis and I'm Madeline
Klein we are here to read thirst tweets
from you disgusting people
[Laughter]
from some
WTF why is the Outer Banks cast so hot
it feels like a backhanded compliment
right it's like they are but why your
guess is as good as ours
killed come to me Madison Bailey please
kiss me no
it's true
Starkey makes me go feral
Madeline Klein in Glass Onion is so fine
like she could Gaslight gatekeep and
girl boss me and I would let her I just
wanted say those are words I personally
live by Outer Banks is actually the
definition of by Panic it's true JJ hot
Kiara
hot Pope hot Sarah hot
there's a lot of questions
I think I think they meant to say and so
on and so forth they ran
actress yeah I'm happy to make anybody
question their sexuality just a little
just think about it the fact that I
would let Rafe Cameron
spit in my mouth shows that I should not
be allowed to make my own decisions in
life feral as long as you know in my
mouth I'm honored
Jonathan Davis looks so hot and do
Revenge new crush unlocked oh yeah do
Revenge was a different era for me Outer
Banks or as I like to call it sexy
Scooby-Doo
the original title actually
[Laughter]
I would let Madeline Klein ruin my life
and then probably say thank you I'd say
you're welcome
how would you do it though Gaslight
girl boss I would let Madison
is so funny
I would let Madison Bailey get me
pregnant no longer a secret admirer I
don't have the talents for that this one
uh especially says true story could rail
me any day respectfully once again I'm
honored Jonathan Davis I have free
tomorrow at 5 PM if you want to go on a
date that sounds nice hold hands and
then redactive redacted so I'm assuming
she was detailing the date and there
were some copyright claims or something
drew Starkey and Jonathan Davis sexy ass
is back on my screen in 2023. I are the
one
we are I would let Sarah Cameron Peg Me
no Thanksgiving oh no there's gonna be
something
wow who allowed Madison Bailey to be
this beautiful this is Criminal please
cuff me choke me do anything you want to
me ma'am I'm flattered Doja Cat lyrics
there before I watched Out remix I
always classified the rich is annoying
and bowed I'd never simp over one until
I met Rafe Cameron and flew up his mask
about like a base
if somebody walked up to you on the
street and said that to you marry me
Jonathan Davis I'm on my knees begging
you to please ruin my life let me be in
charge of your taxes I love my boyfriend
with all my heart I truly do but
Madeline Klein can sit on my face she's
so beautiful I shan't need a chair I'm
20 seconds and 20 seconds into OBX 2 and
Kiara could literally run me over and I
would thank her y'all do not care enough
about y'all's lives we want them ruined
ran over I want to be choked and cops
Kiara would run you over with her her
feet Drew storky could throw me off a
12-story building onto a floor of metal
spikes and I'd still call him daddy
don't think he's calling him nothing
after that good morning to Daddy
Jonathan Davis and only him please run
me over with the truck somebody take us
it appears that certain people are
extremely dehydrated leave with a big
head and a full heart and bass up our
asses tight oh no it won't be
I would say drink your water watch obx3
thanks for watching thanks BuzzFeed
thank you guys thanks guys you shouldn't
have
foreign